Another day.
Another apparent George Santos lie.
New York's new Republican
congressman has repeatedly claim
that his mother
was in the south tower of the Wo
Trade Center on Nine 11.
But New immigration records
obtained by CNN contradict that
Straight now to CNN Sunlen Serfaty
who joins us now
from Washington this morning.
Good morning.
The lies just keep getting worse
and worse.
What do you know at this moment?
They certainly do, Don.
And this is on such a sensitive
how and when his mother died
On multiple occasions,
Santos has claimed
his mother was
in the south tower of the World
Trade Center on Nine 11,
and he's intimated that
that led to her death.
Later on, in 2016
and this is a claim
that was on his campaign website
and he repeated many, many times
Here's how he put it in his own
Just in the last year
my mom was a nine 11 survivor.
She was in the South Tower
and she made it out.
She got caught up in the ash clo
My mom fought cancer till her de
But we now know that his mother
in New York
and was not even in this country
during nine 11.
Newly uncovered immigration reco
that his mother was actually
in Brazil between 1999 and 2003.
Representatives for Santos
Don did not even get back to CNN
when asked about this contradict
Well certainly
I've got to ask you
because we also learned
that Santos allegedly stole $3,0
from a go fund me
that could have saved a sick dog
What do you know about that?
That's right
this was a
go fund me page
that Jorge Santos set up for vet
to help raise funds
for a life
saving procedure
that his pit bull needed at that
And the owner of the dog,
as well
as another veterans veteran,
they're saying
now that they never saw that mon
They never received
the $3,000 that they said
was raised for this dog.
And the veteran says when he tri
and access
the funds, Santos was uncooperat
and getting him the money.
And they
produced these text message exch
with Santos
one where they accuse him
directly at the time
of running a bogus charity.
Santos tells CNN that he has no
what this veterans talking about
What do you make of these?
Because it shows
that his mother
was not apparently in the World
Trade Center on September 11.
That's pretty serious.
A serious time
for a serious incident for our c
in the world.
And then.
Well,
I think broadly
it speaks to his character.
I mean, if you're lying about
your mom's life, he's
also apparently lied
about the time that she died
after various tweets
that have been resurfaced.
He's a dishonest person.
I'd say he's is a bit of a con a
but well,
he's like
the gift
that keeps giving in terms of li
it's kind of funny sometimes.
It's very serious
from a national security perspec
This guy is ripe for adversaries
to exploit, like Scott
and I,
when we are going into governmen
they we go through the SF 86 pro
They look into who you lived wit
They talk to old roommates,
all your old employers
to know that you're not
somebody who could be blackmaile
or subject to corruption.
We don't do that with elected of
It's a little bit different.
The primary basically does that,
and this is a person
who is ripe to be a target for b
and exploitation.
And now he's serving in Congress
and that's dangerous.
This is a person
totally unequipped to be there.
It's the thing is, it's
so now he's lied about nine 11.
He lied about the Holocaust.
He lied about the Pulse
nightclub shooting.
He's lied about these
really serious things.
And I think the thing
is, this is a consistent thing
that he has said
about his mother in nine 11
and he
as he's been caught in
some of these lies has removed
some of them from his campaign w
But as of last night
this one about nine
11 was still on there.
You ever meet people who like
lies so much
and so long about so many
they begin to not be able
to tell the difference.
Yeah that's what this guy had no
name Scott Jennings
Trombley.
Oh, but you know what I mean.
Like,
you just get the impression
that that he has just
lived his entire life
as someone who makes things up
to get through the next few mome
And and if people seem to respon
then he uses it.
And if they don't,
he picks another thing.
And so it's it's quite troubling
I mean, I still think to get rid
out of the Beltway.
If you talk to House Republicans
I mean, nobody wants to associat
with this guy.
They treat him like a pariah.
I think to get rid of him,
it would be good if. Oh, yeah.
Well, you just put on a committe
Yeah.
The the
the two worse committees
that nobody wants to be on.
They stuck him in the dark. Sher
He believes that I have sources
said don't think that he.
How would he know?
I mean, how would he know?
What's a terrible committee?
I mean, they stuck him off in th
A committee, the
Ethics Committee,
these prosecutors,
these people that are looking in
To me,
I think the minute
somebody comes back and says, ye
we've we've sort of validated
all these accusations
and we can now document
without question, either he has
finance problems or,
you know,
whatever it happens to be,
that'll be the trigger for them.
But want to go from excuse me,
want to go from a four person ma
to to a three person majority,
which is something
that Kevin McCarthy is.
And he's probably why
they're sticking with him right
The main reason
that they're sticking with the r
I just want to see
you've worked in government,
but you are
you have been a strategist, righ
Correct. And and an adviser.
What would your advice be
to Kevin McCarthy right now
and to Republicans in Washington
as it relates to George Santo's
to two part plan?
One essentially put him in timeo
which I think they've
they've basically done.
And two,
they really do need to support
the Ethics Committee
moving as quickly as possible
to document
this person's problems
so that they can
then use that as the underpinnin
to toss them out.
You would get rerouted?
Absolutely.
I mean,
if the Ethics Committee says you
and by the way, you may have bro
all these different laws on your
finance paperwork. Absolutely.
Even at this point. Sure.
Okay.
Well, in going a step further, t
if I were Kevin McCarthy,
I would be actively recruiting
in that district
for who another credible
Republican is that could run.
If this is something
that comes to a resignation
and goes to a special action.
It's obviously a D plus one dist
Biden carried it.
So he's worried about what's goi
what would be a difficult uphill
But this guy, one, it's
not that a Republican can't win
Be looking for
who that
moderate businessman or woman
is and try to get them ready to
if that comes to it.
Yeah.
If they don't move on him,
I mean, look,
they're going to toss them out
in the primary next year anyway.
Those voters are
I mean,
this guy's not going to be in Co
you know, in a maximum.
He's going to be in Congress
for two years.
His constituents
have this guy representing them